now for the main course my all-time
favorite shepherd's pie what's the
secret behind a really good shepherd's
pie so we're gonna use leeks and onions
and I'll start browning off the mince
you know no color no flavor I've never
forgotten that you know that color
gotta have color otherwise it puts that
grain tinge on the shepherd's pie that
looks greasy and super nasty they don't
want that to me and I know you don't do
cheaper nasty let me clear your peelings
name thank you very much there's no
nails in there now is that no I remember
you're amazing shepherd's pie and that
lovely little restaurant ease to working
in Sheep Street in Stratford so you
never got food sent back never got a
complaint no apologies work of that
restaurant for gonna make okay a sort of
modern version of nanny's shepherd's pie
[Music]
excuse me sorry and there we got a
delicious steamed trickling date pudding
[Music]
have a skeleton's pull the same I'm not
too sure on the scalloped own once
you're too late come on okay so two cats
are in the race one is called one two
three and the other is called under 12
to one don't know depends who's the
fastest count one two three goes under
to our cast sake
[Music]
tell while you make a nice cup of tea
for nanny yeah thank you very so give
that little file okay nice talk to these
jokes they get worse soon have another
fun
what's the sauce that's gonna get that
really nice spicy seasoning okay yeah
it's about a period you could catch a
little matters in there so if you like
you could yeah put that mince back in
there what's this drained I'm just gonna
put a little touch I know you'll go
crazy at this a little touch the red
wine well because I'm gonna make it nice
and rich okay
but used to have red wine down yeah and
then start covering your mince with your
stock now you'll ring out to the ball
okay and then get some fresh rosemary
okay
like it would taste yes please salt
there's no but hot be careful
either way sorry
looks good as it cooks the house the
wine the alcohol disappear it'll be
delicious
trust me now God spring onions would
chop up and that's going to go through
the mashed potatoes is going to sit on
top nice savory delicious mince is laced
through wet red wine nice so springs
into that please mum and I'm gonna drain
off the potatoes yeah so will dry out
those potatoes and then mash them would
you
Holly slice a little knob of butter in
there for Jack please so what was the
restaurant you work down there were you
a chef well you're a chef I was a cook
it's exactly that not really used to
help me no you kids to know takes us
these are nice and fluffy omelette
oh my and you want them not delicious
mashed potatoes yeah with no lumps in
there it's great having you back in the
kitchen mommy now seriously brings back
good memories
no just why'd you do that don't I just
wants to fork it to get it nice and
spiky so I want that nice crispy topping
and then lightly great that cheddar
cheese on some and that goes in the oven
literally 20 minutes 180 Jack can you
hum the door people I love it doesn't it
even though you said you didn't like it
earlier okay
back in a day mummers meals all came
with two veg and this is no different
but with a modern twist braised peas and
carrots with a fantastic homemade mint
butter
shepherd's pie glaze on top does that
and then the carrots
that's why I didn't put carrots in
sticky spiced chicken wings Jack who's a
hand please book why because it's your
favorites yeah wings okay all right
let's start off with the marinade
tamarind paste him first all that into
there okay so two tablespoons of palm
sugar please
so I heated sugar it's a natural pasture
and it's perfect for marinades
any wings you think you've eaten so far
at the age of thirteen Oh fifty years
yeah a nice sprinkle of chili flakes
depends how hot you like don't forget
the girls you know they start
complaining when you get them too hot
how come you love hot food no actually
love hot food so in there we've got palm
sugar tamarind paste chili flakes some
garlic one nice tablespoon of fish sauce
please Jim looking really good
I'm gonna tablespoons of oil burning in
a nice little taste very good right
wings in get your hands in there and
start rubbing in the marinade please
okay so the secret now is to coat the
chicken wings then all that marinade
yeah yeah how long do you need them in
do you want the longer the better cover
that we can film more shadow excellent
good job
ideally marinate your wings overnight
but half an hour will be enough to get
the flavors going right it's they're
marinated now if you take the trout
people bottle one thank you and then
we're gonna put some tin foil on there
thank you so all that in half it stopped
them from sticking and the wings from
burning so from there a movie dipped in
that marinade and try and get the wing
like that and just sort of scoop it look
like that look at that really nice glaze
on there and then just
it's all that garlic or roast with all
those wings beautifully done
I can make then ready for the oven 170
25 to 30 minutes yep good man
excellent nice wings are in right to go
with my ultimate Southeast Asian dinner
rice cooked in homemade Thai green curry
paste for the easy green curry paste
roughly chopped coriander
lemongrass
green chilies lime leaf shallots garlic
and ginger a glug of oil and blitz the
pace takes minutes to make but it'll
keep for up to 10 days if covered with
oil and stored in a sealed jar in the
fridge to awaken the flavors lime roll
to release the juice next season with
salt and pepper and blend into a smooth
paste
pick the pace until aromatic adding
cooled or leftover rice I love using
fragrant jasmine rice but your standard
long grain rice is great too when
thoroughly heated through serve Thai
green curry paste is so easy to make so
with rice like this it's incredible but
simply add to chicken fish or vegetable
in minutes right now for the green beans
beans in bring the water the ball what's
the first thing I should put in there
beans salt salt so nice pinch of salt in
there yeah so I make an amazing dressing
to Knight tablespoons yep the crunchy
peanut butter please why is it crunchy
I'll give it texture and it will be nice
and sort of chunky green beans in okay
got the rice it's green beans we're
gonna blast them for two two-and-a-half
minutes what is blanching actually mean
lancing means sort of part cooking okay
with a blanch them in boiling water and
then finish them in the pan use the back
of the spoon will be a little easier
please burn off brown sugar and she goes
nice is that little bit too thick maybe
it yeah it is
let's put a little touch more soy sauce
in there let it down
yeah yeah nice and I got a pan on now
all my beans
so no tasty tasty it's so good oh man
hmm Wow have you got the garlic go there
I'm gonna slice the garlic down like
this keep the knife nice and flat and
that way you'll slice through it will
take your time don't worry about the
speed and technique right first just cut
it in half okay your fingers and then
lay the flat side down so it's nice and
sturdy and that nail there out like that
it's just guiding the knife so you can
never cut yourself like that
good I'll drain the beans
nice a little tablespoon of oil pan nice
and hot it's for a garlic and people
only so give that a little toss so will
you toss it push it down push away and
pull back okay a little good push it
down and gently though take your time
nice so push down back up that's it nice
so it's getting nice and golden brown
green beans
I'm drained and they go in now to the
garlic okay with the rice I want you now
spoon the dressing of these and she goes
nice how delicious does that look Wow
what's daddy's policy at home no waste
no waste no waves but now smell that now
doesn't smell of green beans thanks how
nice is that
mmm amazing right
that's the rice that's for green beans
now nori to sprinkle some toasted sesame
seeds on top please
nice and generous with a sesame seed
I'll give the beans a little bit of a
crunch
now all it's left for your favorites to
come out done those being smell amazing
yeah mmm
look at those beauties one for me one
for you Pete I'd like to sprinkle some
spring onions on top please nice
engenders you transformed a very cheap
and cheerful chicken wing yeah okay I'm
over please do not drop them as goober
nice this is my ultimate simple
Southeast Asian dinner sticky spicy
chicken wings Thai green curry rice and
fantastic beans with chili peanut
dressing guaranteed to get the fusses of
eaters into greens when I was living in
France I got to know two very distinct
traditions of French food on the one
hand there was the delicious hors de
cuisine I cooked all day in the
restaurant and another hand there was
the food you ate in people's homes which
is a lot simpler to make but still
absolutely delicious multimap French
inspired lunch spray light bright and
really takes you back to when I lived in
Paris it's my take on the salad nicoise
serve with a delicious goat cheese and
pear tatin think of the Nicoise as an
assembly job of delicious ingredients
brought together with a fantastic
dressing the secret behind my salad
nicoise is in the dressing spoon Dijon
mustard into pestle and mortar some
people top the salad with anchovies and
capers but in mind that the base to the
dressing we're gonna grind that for
paste
and then get the garlic in there
seasoned well with black pepper doesn't
need any salt in there because of the
anchovies add a couple tablespoons of
red wine vinegar olive oil and lastly
flat leaf parsley to give the dressing
freshness against those deep flavors
it's a thick rich substantial dressing
dressing done now for the salad ball
potatoes green beans and eggs from a
rolling ball 7 half to 8 minutes and
should keep that nice
yoky creamy texture in the center once
the eggs are ready put them into cold
water to stop them cooking and this is a
great trick to peel them so much easier
peeling eggs when you use the water but
they've been cooling down in and the
water will seep underneath all the shell
so the whole shell just gets peeled off
with one beautiful big layer now
beans nice and crunchy season the beans
and potatoes whilst they're still warm
so they absorb more flavor a little
drizzle of olive oil salt pepper and
just let them sit there
whilst the potatoes and beans cool down
I'm doing a simple French open sandwich
which is called a tough team this is
delicious
first I'm toasting baguette on the
griddle like the oil a griddle pan get
your bread stick it on there take a pair
it goes brilliantly well with goats
cheese slice the path into finger width
pieces
that's the color we're looking for that
dark crispy texture now for the ghost
cheese give it a season doesn't need
salt because a little fresh goat cheese
is already quite salty and a handful of
crumbled walnuts
they go under the grill whilst I put the
two nice parts together
my secret to assembling a great Nicoise
salad is the start in the middle of the
plate and add ingredients layer by layer
there's one thing I'm always missing the
bottom of salads is dressing so I like
to put it on the plate first baby Jim
lettuce is great because it's robust and
holds that heavy dressing then add firm
waxy celibate aters and green beans I
like them to have a bit of a crunch
canned tuna can be fantastic I'm using a
good quality one in olive oil which has
been drained next baby plum tomatoes
which have a lovely intense sweet flavor
and then I eggs that nice dark rich yo
useful yolk store creamy inside he's a
little olive nice fast this will work
just as well with other black olives and
I'm your dressing drizzle that round
gently beautiful as a Nicoise in heaven
now Tartine Wow
just a smell of those grilled walnuts
that is beautiful a simple but very
elegant Tuna Nicoise the delicious goes
cheese sandwich
wonderful
[Music]
my vibrant and gutsy Nicoise salad with
that incredible anchovy and caper
dressing so with that pear and goat
cheese tatin too good to let the French
keep it all to themselves
[Music]
little courgette ricotta and mint
bruschetta for this recipe you'll need a
griddle pan an essential piece of kit
for that char grill look cut thick
slices of Geppetto bread drizzle both
sides with olive oil
season with a little salt and pepper and
griddle each side until toasted then
slice a couple of courgettes diagonally
into half a centimeter thick pieces
drizzle and coat in olive oil and season
with salt and pepper sear on a smokin
hot griddle pan in batches until all the
causes are bar marked on both sides next
roughly chopped mint leaves and combined
with creamy ricotta cheese spread your
toes sitio petal with dollops of minty
ricotta and top with your seared
courgette
super simple and super tasty now we're
gonna make a delicious
beetroot risotto we to get the shallots
just slice them in half and then just
chop them like that okay now the other
major risotto slots please into the pan
Fedeli and a sprinkle of salt and pepper
along with a couple of crushed cloves of
garlic which you start cooking the
risotto it's really important to have
your stock gently boiling away the
reading cold stock on top of the rice
all the time it just slows down the
process generally you cook a nice wide
flat pan if you cook in a deep pan all
the rice sort of cooks at different
temperatures that's a vegetable stock
you can't have different stocks for
vegetarians angry chickens
I made that mistake once putting beef
stock being a vegetarian soup now I
didn't Mathilde I'm positive I'm joking
well time how nice is that smell it
smells delicious rice in this is our
boil rice it's a pocket rice for risotto
now it's really important to sear the
rice if we were just to put the stock in
without sweating off the rice it goes
all starchy so keep on staring for daddy
it's gonna make a fool no flambe on the
risotto
to go with our deep red beetroot theme
I'm adding red wine followed by the
first ladle of stock to get things
started
now we're off what's coming to the stock
the stock is reducing down and the rice
is sucking it's it that's right so the
device is actually getting nice and
plump money risotto is live one is like
this now we can't stop cooking here we
have to cook it all the way okay ready
for the next table I'm ready
good girl here we go ladle in so we have
to make this for literally 2025 minutes
and we're nursing it all the way
beetroots peel them rub them a little
bit of salt and sugar a little bit of
age bossman believer in there roasted
them and the great
my parmesan how's that vice doing the
race is doing good no that is exactly
where you want to be nello I got that
nice glossy texture to rice so beetroots
want you to put 2/3 of beetroot in there
for me saving 1/3 for the top okay
sprinkle the parmesan in there three
please all over it's snowing again and
then we're just gonna get some nice
butter in there the butter gives the
risotto a really nice loss look at that
beautiful
knock him down let it come down first
might get you speeding they're not funny
beautifully there yeah yes wonderful
shake it risotto should be like lava
just flows out and then the rest of the
be room on top
[Music]
and some extra-virgin olive oil I'll
pick up the bruschetta you take that to
the table okay let's go today